>> Greg: THERE IS NOTHING
BETTER THAN A GOOD OLD
INTELLECTUAL DEBATE.
>> THERE IS A REASON WHY GOD
GAVE YOU TWO EARS AND ONE MOUTH.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO LISTEN.
YOUR FRIEND IS A THUG.
A THUG.
>> A MILLION DOLLARS.
A MILLION DOLLARS.
>> WHERE IS IT?
>> BUCKLE UP.
>> TO TALK ABOUT SOME FANTASY
CRIMINAL INDICTMENT.
>> LET ME TALK ABOUT IT.
IT KEEPS COMING OUT OF YOUR
MOUTH.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
LOOK AT YOU LAUGHING.
>> CAN I SPEAK?
>> CAN I JUST RAISE THAT -- LET
ME CUT THROUGH THE TESTOSTERONE
THAT IS CASCADING AROUND ME.
>> Kimberly: OH, PLEASE.
>> Greg: FROM HIM?
THAT BRINGS BACK MEMORIES.
>> [BLEEP].
>> Greg: CNN, YOU ARE FINALLY
GONE SPRINGER.
ALL THAT IS MISSING HIS HAIR
PULLING AND THE BOUNCER.
I WONDER, COULD THIS BE WHAT
ANDERSON COOPER'S SAW AS A
CAREER ARC TO GO FROM HIGH CLASS
TO CLASS.
FOR WHAT?
TO PROVE TRUMP HAD CONSENSUAL
SEX NOT WITH HIS WIFE BEFORE HE
BECAME PRESIDENT.
I THINK AMERICA FILED IT UNDER
"SO WHAT?"
WE WON'T BESMIRCH THE WOMEN.
WE ARE GOING TO WAIT UNTIL TRUMP
HAS AT LEAST NINE OVAL OFFICE
ENCOUNTERS WITH ONE OF HIS
INTERNS FRESH OUT OF COLLEGE.
UNTIL HE IS ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT BY A WOMAN WHO CAME TO
HIM FOR HELP.
IN THE MEANTIME, ALL WE HAVE IS
A STORY ABOUT A ROMP A DECADE
AGO.
WITH TERM, EVERYONE KNEW HIS
FLAWS BEFORE THEY VOTED.
DECADES AS A TABLOID STAPLE
DIDN'T HURT AS WELL AS THE
PRIZE-WINNING REPORTERS ON THE
TRUMP GOSSIP BEAT.
IN THE ACCESS HOLLYWOOD TAPE
HELPED.
THAT TAPE EXISTED FOR YEARS,
TUCKED AWAY IN A CREEPY NETWORK
DUDES CLOSET.
UNTIL IT WAS LEAKED BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
WHAT ARE THE ODDS OF THAT?
CNN SACRIFICES WHAT'S LEFT OF
ITS REPUTATION TRYING TO UNDO AN
ELECTION.
TO THINK, IF ONLY PEOPLE HAD
ANOTHER CHANCE TO VOTE FOR
HILLARY, THEY WOULD FORGET ABOUT
THE WOMAN WHO RIDICULED HER
HUSBAND'S ACCUSERS.
CONGRATS, CNN, YOU HAVE
REDEFINED HARD NEWS.
SO, K.G.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IN
THIS ANTI-TRUMP MEDIA GOLF BAG,
THE HITLER CLUB DIDN'T WORK.
THE MENTAL INSTABILITY IRON.
THAT DIDN'T WORK.
THEY CAST IRON DIDN'T WORK.
THE COLLUSION PUTTER FAILED.
BRINGING THE SEX SCANDAL WEDGE.
>> Kimberly: IT IS LIKE
ULTIMATE FIGHTING CHAMPIONSHIP
BACK AND FORTH.
VERY UNSETTLING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE POLL
NUMBERS AND WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
PEOPLE AND LIMITED SUPPORT, WHAT
ARE YOU DOING TALKING ABOUT THIS
RIGHT NOW?
THEY SAY THEY HAVE EVIDENCE TO
PROFFER.
IF BETTER BE SOMETHING REALLY
OUTRAGEOUS BECAUSE NOW IT'S LIKE
THEY ARE OVERPROMISING AT RISK
OF UNDER DELIVERING.
EVERYONE GOT THE BIG HYPE ABOUT
THE CNN INTERVIEW WITH ANDERSON.
THERE WAS NOTHING MUCH THEY ARE
WHATSOEVER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS THE POINT
WITH ALL THIS?
THEY ARE TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENCY WITHIN AND
SAY OKAY, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS CONSENSUAL PRIOR TO HIM
BEING PRESIDENT.
OKAY, NOW WHAT?
WHERE'D YOU GO WITH IT?
WHAT ARE THEY TRYING TO DO,
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT WITH THIS?
OR DIRTY THE SITUATION AND
MUDDIED THE WATERS.
>> Greg: CAN WE ROLL A LITTLE
BIT OF TAPE OF MR. CUBAN?
[ALL SPEAKING]
MEANWHILE.
JESSE, IT SEEMS LIKE ANDERSON
COOPER IS PREPARING FOR HIS NEXT
ROLE AS THE MAURY POVICH, THE
NEXT MORNING POVICH.
HE IS GETTING UP THERE.
>> Jesse: I FEEL LIKE CUBAN
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU AND JUAN GO
AFTER EACH OTHER.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
THEY BROUGHT IN CUBAN BECAUSE
AVENATTI GOT HIS CLOCK CLEANED
AND HE COULDN'T TAKE COHEN'S
LAWYER ON.
HE WAS DRINKING WATER AND HE
WOULDN'T LOOK HIM IN THE EYE.
HE WAS ASKING COOPER FOR HELP
HALF THE TIME.
IT WAS NOT A FAIR FIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE WHY.
YOU DON'T THINK DONALD TRUMP CAN
HAMMER OUT AN IRONCLAD NDA?
IT'S DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS AIRTIGHT.
IT IS LOCKED DOWN.
EVERY TIME HE BREAKS IT, IT'S A
MILLION-DOLLAR JUDGMENT.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
IT'S NOT LIKE WHEN YOU GO ON
CNN, THAT'S ONE TIME YOU BREAK
IT.
EVERYTHING, EVERY TIME YOU SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT IT, YOU BREAK IT
AND THAT'S A MILLION DOLLARS.
HE IS A TERRIBLE LAWYER.
HE'S PROBABLY GOING TO GET SUED
BY STORMY FOR MALPRACTICE WE
BETTER HAVE A LOT OF INSURANCE.
THIS WHOLE THING WHERE THEY ARE
TEASING THAT THEY HAVE A DVD.
IT'S REVENGE PORN.
IT'S ILLEGAL TO DO THAT IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY ALSO HAVE A DOCTORED LIE
DETECTOR TEST VIDEO.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT'S DOCTORED.
CNN, YOU SAY --
JUAN IS LAUGHING.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
THROW IN.
YOU HAVE CNN WHOSE BRAND IS HARD
NEWS AND REAL NEWS AND THEY
CHASED A RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR.
THAT HASN'T WORKED, SO THEY ARE
PIVOTING TO A PORN STAR.
IF YOU POLL PEOPLE AND SAY WHAT
ARE YOUR ISSUES?
RUSSIA AND STORMY ARE NOT
ISSUES.
THEY LOST THE PULSE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND NOT EVEN
SANJAY GUPTA CAN FIND IT?
>> Greg: NICE ENDING.
>> Juan: I REMEMBER WHEN
EVERYONE HERE AT FOX WAS SO
UPSET ABOUT JOHN EDWARDS.
OF COURSE IT LED TO A TRIAL.
I THINK --
>> Kimberly: IT LED TO A
BATHROOM STALL WHERE HE WAS
HIDING.
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S ALSO THE
CASE WHERE THERE WAS A MISTRIAL
AND AN ACQUITTAL ON ONE COUNT OR
SOMETHING.
IT WAS A TRIAL.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE REALLY COME
AWAY FROM ALL THE SCANDAL IS A
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS WAS AN IN-KIND CONTRIBUTION
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN JUST
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
$130,000 PAYMENT.
I DON'T THINK CNN PAID THE
$130,000.
I THINK THAT WAS DONE BY MICHAEL
COHEN, MR. TRUMP'S PERSONAL
LAWYER.
I THINK THERE'S A REAL ISSUE
HERE, AND DON'T FORGET WHEN YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT OH, GOSH,
BILL CLINTON, PORNOGRAPHY, CNN.
I THINK, YOU TALK ABOUT IRONS
THAT THE RIGHT WING USES TO TRY
TO DISTRACT FROM THE OUTRAGEOUS
BEHAVIOR AT STAKE HERE.
I THINK BOTH SIDES, IT SEEMS TO
ME, REACHING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO REACH TO SAY
AS AN EVANGELICAL CHRISTIAN
RIGHT NOW, YOU SEE, ESPECIALLY
THE EVANGELICAL CHRISTIAN WHITE
WOMEN ARE STARTING TO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS.
>> Greg: I PUT RAPE ABOVE
EVERYTHING ELSE, BUT THAT'S JUST
ME.
DANA, YOU WORRY ABOUT TRUMP
BEING BLACKMAILED BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE THE MEDIA IS DOING THE
EXTORTING.
>> Dana: I THINK STORMIE WOULD
BE BETTER SERVED IF HER LAWYER
WAS QUIETER AND CLASSIER.
SHE COMPORTED HERSELF WHILE IN
THE "60 MINUTES" INTERVIEW AND I
WOULD PREFER MY LAWYER TO JUST
DO THE LAWYERING.
NOT DO THE PUNDITRY.
I DON'T TAKE IT'S NECESSARY AND
IT DOESN'T HELP HER.
ALSO I PULLED UP A STATISTIC
TODAY, I WAS ON CAPITOL HILL WAY
BACK WHEN.
MY FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF IS
HERE.
WATCHED THE WHOLE ENTIRE
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WENT ON IN THE LATE
1990s.
IN 1997, BILL CLINTON, WHEN THIS
ALL STARTED, HAD A 59% APPROVAL
RATING WHICH IS PRETTY GOOD.
A YEAR LATER AFTER IT ALL WENT
DOWN, ALL OF THE MEDIA COVERAGE,
THE HEARINGS, EVERYTHING.
IN JANUARY OF 1998 HAD A 69%
APPROVAL RATING.
I UNDERSTAND WHY DEMOCRATS WOULD
WANT TO TRY TO DO THIS BECAUSE
THEY THINK IT MIGHT WORK.
I JUST KNOW THAT FROM
REPUBLICANS, REPUBLICANS LEARNED
A BIG LESSON.
>> Greg: I THINK THE LESSON IS
SOME OF THIS HAS A REBOUND